so we just said last night in the show
we highlighted what is a remarkable and
very sad story more than a quarter
century after the end of apartheid South
Africa once again becoming a place where
an entire group of people is targeted
for discrimination and violence on the
basis of their skin color we oppose that
obviously it was wrong 25 years ago it
is wrong now it is wrong wherever and
whenever it happens so we call the State
Department to get their view of what is
currently happening in South Africa
because America's moral leadership still
does matter they told us they didn't
care
confiscating property without
compensation is fine they said in effect
because South Africa was quote a strong
democracy whatever that means
pretty shocking we're not the only ones
who found that answer hard to believe by
the way the Washington Post insinuated
today that we made that up unfortunately
did not the president's our segment last
night and he tweeted this response to it
quote I have asked Secretary of State
Pompeo to closely study the South Africa
land and farm seizures and
expropriations and the large scale
killings of farmers we should say that
we did talk about the land seizures on
the show last night we did not address
the killings that he referred to we did
mention the threat of violence but any
case today the State Department
elaborated on the president's tweet
here's part of it I should mention that
the ex-pro creation of land without
compensation our position is that that
would risk sending South Africa down the
wrong path we continue to encourage a
peaceful and transparent public debate
about what we consider to be a very
important issue in the South Africans
certainly do as well so I mean that was
kind of tepid I guess it's not gonna
solve the problem but it's basically
good news pushing back against racial
discrimination is always worth doing and
yet for some reason a reason no one
really explained luminaries in the media
disagreed they were offended by that in
an Orwellian turn various news outlets
suggested it was somehow racist to
oppose the racist policies of the South
African government even nazi-like watch
he goes to race and what better way than
to give this neo-nazi propaganda that
white farmers are being killed in South
Africa when in fact that is not true not
based on them being white so show that
clip to anyone who knows South Africa
who lives there and see how they respond
to laughs bitterly it's ludicrous
it's a lie the president of the country
seal Ramapo Xia has pledged to change
South Africa's Constitution in order to
legalize the seizure of property without
compensation that's currently being
debated in the parliament in South
Africa even now the government is trying
to confiscate 2-game farms after the
owners refused to sell at a fraction of
the market price everyone in the country
understands what these are their racial
attacks okay say defenders of the South
African government in this country but
previous generations in South Africa
under the apartheid government also
seized land on racial grounds by the way
that is absolutely true they did do that
and it's one of the reasons that so many
decent people in this country and around
the world opposed a part eight part
eight was awful and wrong things have
changed though now our elites endorsed
the idea of a racial spoil system and
that's the scariest part it's far more
ominous that whenever the corrupt and
incompetent government of South Africa
is doing our ruling class now believes
in collective punishment that is the
opposite of justice nobody is alleging
that individual farm owners in South
Africa stole their land instead the
claim is that people who resemble them
did and that's enough our elites see no
problem with that standard that should
worry you a lot if you got mugged how
would you feel about imprisoning someone
who just happened to look like the
mugger how about the muggers children
should they be punished too if they'll
sound like insane questions that's
because they are insane questions in the
West we punish only the guilty we do not
punish their descendants or everyone
with the same hair and eye color for
more than 200 years pretty much
everybody in America agreed on those
terms now the people who run our country
aren't so sure
increasingly they think that
generational guilt seems like a fine
standard but where does that end up for
a preview let's go back to South Africa
Julius Malema is the leader of the
country's third largest political party
he's one of South Africa's most famous
figures here's what he said two years
ago about murdering people on the basis
of their skin colour watch this
I don't know what's going to happen in
the future I'm saying to you we've not
called for the killing of white people
at least for now I can't guarantee the
future yeah but I mean you'd understand
somebody watching that especially as it
gets shared on Twitter they freak out it
sounds like a genocide Oh crybabies
Malema hasn't become any more moderate
he's become more radical and not
coincidentally he's become more popular
here's Malema just a few months ago when
you want to eat them heart go after a
white man they feel a terrible pain to
starting with this whiteness who are
cutting the throat of what Nessa jangle
ah Melina by the way is not a fringe
figure in South African politics he's a
pivotal figure in South African politics
he saw the president's tweet last night
and much like the Washington Post Malema
was offended by it notice how he makes
certain to blame Jews for good measure
watches this is from today Donald Trump
is not saying anything we have not heard
from white people there's a group of
white right-wingers who are being
trained by Jews in Korea to be snipers
only death will stop us not Trump not
poverty not sanctions that right there
is what our ruling class is now
defending it does make you wonder about
their motives Christian witness a former
State Department senior adviser under
presidents Trump and George W Bush and
he joins us and Christian great to see
you good to see so there are many levels
here South Africa is the most modern
really the only really modern country in
Africa it's a great country it's worth
helping them not slide into sin Bob way
territory but there's also a moral level
why is it so hard for the State
Department to say no that's wrong we're
not for that yeah you have client Titus
here and this happens in what we call
the regional bureaus at the State
Department you have an East Asia Bureau
in this case in Africa Bureau and too
often they end up representing the
interests of the government the foreign
government to us as opposed to the real
job which is to represent our interest
to them you saw that in the original
statement out of the State Department
very weak defending South Africa and
completely glossing
for the murder happening there why would
I mean look anybody one of our producers
married to a South African South
Africans working here of all political
backgrounds but he talked to anybody who
lives in the country the first thing
I'll say is well why would you take
statistics from the government at face
value that's insane and in our State
Department does why aren't they more
sophisticated or do they know if they're
false I don't think they know I think
there's a lot of ignorance about this
issue you know this is one of the sort
of unauthorized victim groups around the
world we have authorized ones that were
allowed to be concerned about you know
the various minority groups but when it
comes to the President or other people
the vice-president defending Christians
in the Middle East even defending
Muslims in Burma defending Christians in
Burma who are also beleaguered 60
churches burned there defending Muslims
in China these are not the ordinary
victim groups that the Left cares about
and that flows over to our state
department bureaucracy at times
unfortunately and so you see just not a
lot of regard and interest for this we
also don't have a political ambassador
yet down in South Africa which means
that our representation down there
frankly is weak yeah and just to be
totally clear I I'm very wary of getting
too involved in the internal dealings of
any of any country unless it directly
benefits the Unites States so I'm not
calling for any dramatic action but
people do listen to what our State
Department says and it seems like it
would just be low cost to say you know
the United States doesn't think that you
should punish people on the basis of
their appearance also we can just tell a
very very topical historical lesson if
you will and we can without you know
anything with the military with
intelligence just be honest about this
what's going on in South Africa right
now happen next door nearby in Zimbabwe
beginning around 2000 Robert Mugabe
going after white farmers there the same
stuff where it's a combination of
political intimidation and then violence
by thugs they push more and more white
farmers out that actually has led to
food shortages in zimba in the poorest
country on planet Earth for a while
because of that so is the president do
you think can it gonna keep up with this
issue or is it the criticism do you
think gonna slow him down now I think
that you know across the board the
president has been very good about some
of the Forgotten people not only here in
the United States but people who around
the world I believe good I mentioned
Christians in the Middle East really had
no one
from Trump speaking up for them not even
the Pope not anyone like that so I think
you're going to see this and you know
Pompeo has been by necessity very
focused North Korea Iran Syria right
this is as you point out not an area
where there are fundamental US interests
at stake that's we're saying we're
actually doing a segment later in the
show with Marco Rubio on Muslims being
persecuted in China because it's not and
I know the reaction is oh this is
tribalism it's not actually there's a
principle here that's worth defending
and we're gonna continue to and I hope
the president will crystal Witten thank
you very much thanks doctor great to see
you